97% of the galaxies in the observable
universe are moving away from us faster
than the speed of light but how can this
be true when one of the unbreakable laws
of the universe is that nothing can
travel faster than light the answer is
that Einstein's theory of special
relativity the rules that dictate this
only applies to things traveling through
space for these distant galaxies aren't
getting further away from us because
they're moving through space but because
the space between us is expanding so the
distance between us and them is
increasing faster than light could
travel across that space to get your
head around this bizarre situation
here's a couple of popular analogies
imagine I'm having a birthday party for
anteaters and I'm blowing up a balloon
covered in ants as the balloon inflates
the ants get further away from each
other
even if they're standing still the ants
are like the galaxies in the balloon the
expanding space for this picture isn't
very satisfying because space is
3-dimensional not two-dimensional like
the surface of the balloon so I can do a
little better
imagine I'm baking some bread with ants
in it for this weird anteater party the
ants are scattered through the dough and
as the dough proves they expand making
the ants get further away from each
other again but this time in 3d space
note that the ants don't get any bigger
they stay the same size this is just
like the galaxies whose gravity is much
stronger than the force that's causing
space to expand which we call dark
energy so galaxies solar systems stars
and planets all stay the same size
despite the expanding space they live in
the other caveat to this analogy is that
space isn't expanding into anything else
like the oven space is everything and
it's all expanding a key result of this
is that galaxies that are further away
from each other will move away from each
other faster this is a natural result of
the expanding space-time to explain this
better let's look at a simple
one-dimensional example where the
galaxies in the middle we look at two
galaxies that are exactly one mega
parsec away in each direction a mega
parsec is about 3.26 million light-years
according to the measurements of
astrophysicists space is expanding by
roughly 70 kilometers per second per
megaparsec so these other galaxies are
moving away from us at 70
as per second just from the expansion of
space now let's see what this looks like
from the leftmost galaxy they would see
our original galaxy moving away at 70
kilometers per second but the second
galaxy would be moving away twice as
fast and another galaxy that's a further
three mega parsecs away would be
retreating three times as fast and you
can see that the further and further
away you go the faster and faster this
speed gets until you reach a point where
the distant galaxies are moving away
from us faster than light this leads to
some pretty mind-bending facts when we
see a distant galaxy because the light
has been traveling through space for a
long time we see the galaxy as it was in
the distant past but that same light
tells us how far away the galaxy is
right now not how far away it was when
the light was emitted for example let's
look at the most distant galaxies we've
ever observed GN said 11 it's currently
32 billion light-years away but we see
it as it was just four hundred million
years after the Big Bang some thirteen
point five billion years ago if we keep
looking beyond she ends at 11 we keep
looking further back in time until we
hit the limits of the cosmic horizon the
Cosmic Microwave Background and the Big
Bang although the universe is 13.8
billion years old the cosmic horizon is
further away at 45 billion light-years
and this difference is because of the
cosmic expansion so today we observe
galaxies where they are now but as they
were millions or billions of years ago
to make this concrete let's tell the
story of us in this galaxy at the Big
Bang the atoms that will end up making
us and she ends at 11 were right next to
each other because everything in the
observable universe was packed into a
tiny volume over the next 400 million
years space expanded the first
generation of stars formed and exploded
then gravity pulled their remnants into
the second generation of stars this is
where our atoms were 400 million years
after the Big Bang when the young
galaxies chiens at 11 sitting just 2.6
billion light years away emitted some
light in our direction this light
traveled through space towards us for
the next thirteen point five billion
years
the second generation of stars exploded
in their remnants went on to form our
galaxy in our Sun which is a third
generation star all this time the light
from TMZ 11 was being stretched as the
space it moved through was expanding his
courses wavelength to get longer and
longer which is called a redshift and
today the light finally reaches the
lenses of the telescope's of our semi
intelligent tapes and from the redshift
of the light we can tell that right now
GM Z 11 is 32 billion light years away I
say right now but gnz 11 doesn't exist
anymore it's stuff will have turned into
some other stars or galaxies a long time
ago but whatever it is now because it's
so far away it's moving away from us
faster than the speed of light so no
light it emits right now will ever reach
us so here's a question how much of the
universe is moving away from us faster
than the speed of light it turns out 97%
of the stars and galaxies are so there's
like an invisible sphere of
inaccessibility at about 13 billion
light years where even if you had a
magical spacecraft that could somehow
travel at the speed of light we'd never
be able to travel beyond it okay so now
we get to the physics puzzle I mentioned
at the beginning of the video can you
work out how to calculate how many of
the galaxies in the observable universe
are moving away from us faster than the
speed of light all of the information
you need to solve this problem is
contained within this video so give it a
go I thought it'd be a fun thing to try
I've got 97% and I'll be posting my
solution in exactly two days but if you
want to discuss your own solutions we
can use the comment section below okay
now on to the last bit of this video
which is really kind of mind-bending
so we have two boundaries in our
universe one at the edge of the
observable universe and the other is
this sphere of inaccessibility where no
signal we send today will ever be able
to reach beyond it the question is how
will these boundaries move in the future
for each one will it get bigger or
smaller or stay the same size pause the
video now if you want to take a guess
yourself
unsurprisingly because of the
accelerating expansion of space the
sphere of inaccessibility is shrinking
so as time goes on less and less of the
universe would ever see any signal we
admit today in fact every year about 20
million stars slip forever beyond our
reach
as for the edge of the observable
universe the opposite is happening it's
increasing in size over time which blew
my mind when I learned it because it
seems opposite to my intuition about the
expanding universe as time passes more
and more galaxies will slip into view at
the edge of the observable universe and
right now we can see more of the
universe that we've ever been able to
see in the history of the earth the
reason for this is that the light from
the galaxies that are currently outside
the observable universe is already well
on its way to reach us and over time
more and more of that light as time to
reach us so in the future we've got more
time to see more of the universe but
remember we will only ever see these
galaxies as they were very soon after
the Big Bang
we'll never see them as they are today
so it's kind of bittersweet to think
that in the far future we'll be able to
see more or more of the universe but
we'll be in touch with less and less the
sponsor of this video is brilliant in
these times if you're looking for more
puzzles to solve it's a veritable
treasure trove of activities to keep
your mind busy they have courses on many
of my favorite subjects within physics
mathematics and computer science like
calculus quantum computing and of course
special relativity in the courses you do
a combination of learning and problem
solving and there are many interactive
tools that you can investigate to help
you build up an intuition for the
subjects so if you're looking for
something to keep yourself or your
family members busy and learn some real
Science and Mathematics you should
definitely check it out and if you like
what you see the first 200 people to
sign up from this channel for the paid
subscription will get a 20% discount off
their membership just go to brilliant
dot org slash do s or click on the link
in the description below and thanks to
brilliant for the continued support of
my videos
[Music]